did you guys know who I was I have to
feeling you did not know no it's all
good you don't have to I just hope
you're in you're from Oregon Wow
what's it like over there it's green
well it's weird because you guys are so
liberal and these guys aren't but also
y'all don't have to deal with Mexicans
everyday you know I don't know I just
put it together as I was thinking about
how liberal yours like it's easy to be
liberal when all you're dealing with his
white people look I'm tired of these
[ __ ] man hate white liberals
man I'm so sick of them
I hate him dude
telling you man I miss white
conservatives I'm a little upset
nobody's asked to check my papers over
here let's wait now that only happen to
the Latinos yeah anybody any Latino here
ever actually been my papers checked
oh what a miss that's disappointing man
thought it was poppin off down here
you're sneaky who are Mexicans yo you
are sneaky you guys I thought you were
white so that is pretty sneaky guys you
probably just walked right around that
wall huh you guys do your thing I'm
gonna just pull that hell no I think I'm
I'm Blanco you know I mean he's just a
lot it's just a lot I was in Oregon they
were doing a lot I was actually in
Portland so maybe that's like the super
consensus that's just your rule oh you
were the ones that we're trying to get
them [ __ ] white Hindus out of Oregon
what they call that [ __ ] again
that was the documentary on Netflix
about the huh oh sure yeah where are you
from I can't tell you that kina or
Indian yes sir
I see why white people get confused by
this
hey I'll get us mixed up now there's a
lot of similarities like he knows and
you look kind of similar and I mean both
very close to our families you guys are
just dumb Indians let's be honest if we
were good at manual labor
we'd be y'all and if you are good at
numbers you'd be us it's the same the
same basic thing the guy's families just
park wherever the [ __ ] you don't really
care
zoning means nothing to us